Film Courage: Gary, what’s the greatest
script you’ve ever read and what happened
to that script?
Gary W. Goldstein: Wow...You know, I’ve
read a lot of what I would consider...I’ve
been blessed to read a lot of great scripts.
And some of them never got made, fortunately
many have. I remember reading the MILLION
DOLLAR HOTEL by a friend of mine (Nicholas
Klein) and I was so endlessly in love with
that script. And I wanted him to direct (he
had never directed). It ended up being directed
by Wim Wenders and (in my estimation) it didn’t
have the poetry that was Nicholas that was
infused in it because of who he was. No disrespect
to Wim Wenders. He’s a lauded filmmaker
of course. But in that case, it kind of went
one direction.
PRETTY WOMAN before it was PRETTY WOMAN (3000)
by J. F. Lawton was certainly at that time
the best script I’d ever held in my hands.
And it was a dark drama of course but it was
absolutely riveting, compelling, in a sort
of tragic sense. And of course as we know
that film did get made, only it got...ironically
the film got made so true to its original
form, but just the structure and the characters
and the dialogue was so taught that we didn’t
have to labor to turn it tonally. And of course,
we had Garry Marshall, so he could improv anything.
He filmed it as it was and then he did a little
improv and we found that sort of comedy in
it.
So that got made, again...in a totally different
direction. Originally it was going to be a
dark independent, few-million-dollar-film.
So you never know? These things always take
left turns.
But there have been a lot of great scripts
that sadly didn’t get made. I remember there
was a little film called THE CURE that I was
madly in love with. A very special small script,
young characters. And I had actually shared
that with Steven Spielberg and his people
flipped out. And then Steven fell in love
with it and we were cranking up the offer
from Universal and Warner Brothers simultaneously.
The agent actually sold the script overnight
to a third party and it got made years later
as a low-budget, kind of non-event. That was
the biggest heartbreak personally for me.
But you never know. There are scripts today
that probably still haven’t been made that
will get made that I think are amazing. There’s
no predicting this business.
Film Courage: So what was it about that script
where you said was eventually sold to a third-party?
I mean what was it that just really resonated
with you? Was it a personal thing that you
felt a connection to? Or the way it was written,
the voice of the protagonist?
Gary W. Goldstein: What was so remarkable
about it was there are characters and stories
that are so gorgeous because of their truth,
because they call to us, they penetrate us
in a way that is undeniable. That all of us
have had that experience growing up. And this
[script] was about growing up...young characters.
And anyone who has blood flowing through their
veins would have recognized some part of themselves
or their friends in that story in a very poignant
context. Because it was so universal and so
sweetly done, it wasn’t a sweet picture,
it was a challenging story. But what was sweet
about it was the attention to detail, the
truth of how it played out.